Yeah,
how do you change an entire industry for
Jeff Bezos and his new grocery store of
the future?
Amazon go.
It's a three part process in no
particular order.
Part one,
make a video with over 7 million views.
Amazon's youtube video is a bit of
Utopian science fiction,
a vision for what the future of grocery
shopping could look like and almost
completely frictionless consumer
experience in which you walk in,
grab what you want and go.
The marketing here is extremely
important.
I think.
Notice that Amazon drop this video like
beyonce drops a surprise album and they
made sure to disable the comments and
declined to take questions about the
concept from journalists for the time
being.
I think the point is to let the idea
gestate in the public's mind,
letting us internalize the ease and
stress free environment of our future
grocery stores.
This internalization that hope goes will
flower into an expectation and
expectation is a very powerful force
that can move markets.
This potential for change is crucial for
the second important thing part to get
the patents in 2013 and 2014.
Amazon filed two patents that describe
most of the advanced technology we're
seeing inside the Amazon go store.
The first call detecting item
interaction and movement describes a
system for tracking removal or placement
of items at inventory locations,
just like you saw on the video using a
variety of sensors and cameras with
object recognition software.
The second expands on this concept
covering the payment of items when you
leave a designated area.
Now,
both these patents were filed primarily
for use in Amazon's warehouses,
but even then they were putting in
little hints about their longer term
goals.
I think I don't see what you're doing.
What are we doing?
Part prove that once Amazon creates the
expectation for a customer experience
defined by technology that they own,
the logical thing to do would be to
start building the Amazon go stores.
You're likely to see Amazon start doing
that once they fix all the bugs with
their Beta location in Seattle,
but I think this obscures the much
bigger fish that Amazon is trying to
catch here.
To understand what I'm talking about,
you have to look at another part of
Amazon's business,
Amazon web services.
The massive cloud computing Juggernaut
that as of 2016 is the most profitable
segment of Amazon's entire business.
Basically years ago,
Amazon built an online infrastructure to
host and organize its own site and then
they realized that they could take this
technology and license it to other
companies from this.
Amazon collects billions in fees.
The Internet,
as you know,
it wouldn't exist without Amazon web
services,
Netflix,
NASA,
Reddit,
the Obama campaign,
pinterest and the CIA are all hosted on
its servers and a lot more.
It's a business that's growing fast and
it's 10 times the size of its next 14
competitors combined.
It was Brian Romilly that payment's
expert who pointed me in the direction
of Amazon web services and and once you
learn that business model,
it's easy to predict where Amazon is
heading.
They want to combine their patents with
marketing that creates this expectation
of a frictionless shopping experience.
Then they'll build a number of stores to
prove the concept.
By the time they have a few 100 and
operation,
the amount of refined targeted data that
we'll be able to acquire on customers
will make the model irresistible.
Komodo,
welcome back to the gap sort of tank
tops for gap for you and that point
Amazon just has to wait.
Supermarket chains nowhere near capable
of retrofitting their stores with this
kind of tech will have one shiny place
to turn for all their needs and just
like it does with its web services.
Amazon will license like crazy with
their eyes toward dominating not just
supermarkets,
but the entire retail universe.
A $25,000,000,000,000
industry in the US alone.
In other words,
Amazon go is just,
hey everybody,
thanks for watching.
Happy holidays.
I hope that you're with people that you
love.
This holiday season.
The nerdfighter is like insanely close
to a million subscribers,
which is messing with my head a little
bit,
but if you want to help me get there,
you can subscribe to the channel by
clicking this box that I've set up right
over there.
That's a huge milestone for me.
20 16 has been the best year of my life
in huge part.
Thanks to you guys and everybody who
watches the show,
everybody who's come onto the show this
year and has really made this project
something really special.
Thank you so much.
You're the best fans ever.
I'll see all of you next Wednesday.